hi I'm Maz Jobrani and I'm Persian like
the cat yeah I can't imagine anything
more terrifying than having to stand on
a stage like this and tell jokes in
front of an audience this big let alone
jokes about Middle Easterners or Islam
or terrorism but that's exactly what Maz
Jobrani is about to do and I'm here to
interview him before his show this thing
on contrary to what some Americans think
the whole area is not one country
have the same types of Sweden but I've
run into conversations there with some
people just bomb the whole game just
bombing as you mentioned in your book
and the title of the book you've taken
on the role of terrorists yes what were
you thinking at the time and you have
any regrets about that you know when you
first start out in Hollywood the types
of parts you get when they find out
you're Middle Eastern descent tend to be
parts where you play terrorists so pre
9/11 I got a role in a Chuck Norris
movie of the week
the closer I get the more peaceful I
become it was my first experience doing
something like that and when I went home
we were filmed in Dallas when I got back
to LA I told my agent I said no more
terrorist parts and that's when the TV
show 24 called and they said we have a
terrorist part and I said no and they
said but he changes his mind halfway
through the mission I was like ah the
ambivalent terrorists I could do that so
that was the last time I played one of
the roles and that was well over like
that was probably 15 years ago or so and
I have not done any more auditions for
those parts those are the parts that are
available unfortunately and I think it
takes more and more people from that
part of the world or that have grown
that have backgrounds from that part of
the world to get involved in filmmaking
and writing for us to start having other
stories told that show us in a different
light so let me challenge you here
because we're talking about taking on
problematic roles and you're gonna be
playing Jafar in an upcoming Disney
movie called descendants about the
villains yeah a lot of people had
problems with the with the character of
Jafar in fact back in the day one of the
leading Arab rights groups denounced the
film Aladdin for being racist no how do
you reconcile it as well as a smaller
part in it in a bigger movie and
secondly I have no problem playing bad
guys or villains you know and and I
understand the criticisms of Aladdin I
understand those and and I probably
agree with some of those but I've no
problem playing bad guys like I keep
saying I like I want to rob a bank in a
movie but I would just like to do it
with a gun and not a bomb strapped
around okay let's do
shamsher John Machine Jim shit Jamshid
shitty shit in the she'd just call me
Jimmy how much of your comedy is about
dispelling stereotypes about Iranians or
Arabs or Muslims and how much of it
actually kind of like plays on that or
propels them just for a laugh I was one
of the first comedians from this part of
the world to talk about you know to
start going to stand up and and it's not
that I chose to be one of the first but
like it was me and I met Ahmed and Aron
Kader and Dean Obeidallah who was doing
the axis of evil comedy tour this was
like seven eight years ago on Comedy
Central
it came out and we were looking at what
people were saying online and one guy in
a conservative chatroom he said I never
knew these people laughed that's a big
thing
I mean think about it you've never had
people from the Middle East telling
jokes on American television and
laughing and part of it was when they
would show the audience and there's an
audience of people looking like you
laughing I think people were shocked I'd
like you both to behave tonight by the
way okay Palestinian I don't want you
like throwing anything at the jeweler
like rocks or you know Molotov cocktails
you keep that to yourself
Chihuahua in a behave don't take her
seat that's their seat letter papers
we've said in the past that when going
to the Middle East to avoid sex religion
and politics yes but when defines Middle
Easterners the other than those three
things
yeah his ways to kind of skirt it you
know and I've seen what's been greatest
since we went out about 17 years ago
2007 we came out there's now become
there's now a stand-up comedy scene in a
lot of these countries and there's young
people who are talking about local
politics and getting away with it and
it's a beautiful thing and the way I
compare it is in the u.s. 50 60 years
ago Lenny Bruce was a comedian who would
say things that would get him in trouble
he was being arrested after his shows
and I feel like hopefully in the Middle
East these kids that are starting to do
stand-up
you know stand-up is very new to that
part of the world so I'm hoping that as
the years go by people start to open up
to it and these young kids who are doing
stand-up there in 50 60 years it'll be a
much more open society in that way
you